all the trucks are passing us I'm doing
80 in this big rig sails right past like
an ocean liner
but we're on the 85 out of on
approaching Frankfurt we've been on the
road in this Mercedes b-class for 16
hours now and have hardly travelled more
than 200 kilometers and now the gauge
says it needs a charge again so we leave
the outer bond and drive into an
industrial area in search of power
that's okay it's all hooked up nada
charged by hotline
oh no I'm seriously supposed to call RWE
in the middle of the night
yah hello 1m2 aji makers were at a
charging point and I'd like to activate
no we don't have a contract ie a nine -
oh eight - seven huh ah okay now it's
switched on and I can see the cars
charging super many thanks super what
was your name again
that's Christ a Shriner many thanks bye
bye truth we had to spend the night
no tell in Frankfurt anyway because the
car took nine hours to charge so our
appointment in the sauerland is hanging
in the balance
Hoda not the 157 km/h on Italian
well here we are back in the right lane
doing 80 kilometres an hour trying to
save juice our B class will need one
more charge at long last we've arrived
in this small West German town we hope
somebody here can tell us what's wrong
Medicus is the specialist for charging
points and cables the company developed
the standard connector being adopted
throughout Europe can we see what kind
of cable this was really didn't work
with the B Class I see it from here see
there
what company made this cable we made it
but that cable can only charge three
point seven kilowatts you know serious
yes and the car takes 11 kilowatts but
you need a thicker cable this one's too
small are you telling me that the king
of German car makers Mercedes lent us a
demonstrator to promote a mobility and
gave us the wrong cable no I think
somebody who didn't know any better just
made a mistake
okay let's give it a try no I want to
see how fast the counter goes if the amp
ere's or bolts or whatever just zipped
through indeed for the first time the
Mercedes is charging the way it should
and in barely three hours the battery is
topped up
without the charging stress of the past
few days the beat class is pretty fast
with some 400 kilometers on the odometer
we arrived in Wolfsburg
Matthews driving electric still fun with
John it depends on the car some of the
time the big class wasn't really easy
basic real torture we had the wrong
cable that cable meant we once had to
charge it for nine hours overnight if we
couldn't turn on the air conditioning
despite the heat because we had to save
our electricity to keep talking because
we couldn't turn on the radio either no
that uses electricity too we got to know
each other better I'm not sure I wanted
to
next morning we turn in our B Class
Mercedes it heads off on its return trip
to strut guard in a trailer our next car
is again from volkswagen the VW e-golf
volkswagen has recently announced an e
mobility offensive what sets this golf
apart from the gasoline-powered golf's
on the outside it looks just the same it
looks the same and it handles much the
same - except that it glides along very
quietly you just don't have the engine
noises especially at low speeds a very
pleasant way to drive in town how many
of these cars have you sold last year we
sold about 15,000 eGolf s-- most of them
to norway at the moment norway is the
electric car market in europe but more
and more markets are discovering a
mobility VW plans to introduce 30 at
least partially electric models by 2025
they could account for a quarter of the
group's total car sales or over two
million units a change
VW desperately needs after its emissions
scandal with diesel models 29 you can
give it something are you under pressure
because of dieselgate to push more
strongly for the e-mobility offensive
the diesel issues have given impetus to
the e mobility initiatives no question
but even so this is the path we had
started on even before that we set out
from Berlin two weeks ago in a VW and
now we're heading back to the capital in
another VW we've driven almost 2,500
kilometers around Germany tested five
electric cars and charged our batteries
25 times
you're Kim I think we look like we've
covered 2500 kilometers in electric cars
right how was it for you it was fun but
not always plodding along in the
slipstream of trucks cutting down
charging points never knowing how to
activate them the technical jargon but
now we're almost professionals
professionals we know what cards are
available what cables to use and we made
it back to Berlin on 100% electric but I
don't think e-mobility is going anywhere
unless they solved the chaos with the
charging stations there be more charging
points and they have to be easier to use
the ultimate cars are okay and I think
the automakers have plans for what's to
come but until that time I'd say in
Berlin I'm going to stick with my
bicycle yes me too